let's first just read a bit of this
first story so we can uh get to ragging
on republicans
it's from the daily mail forget trump
and move on
mitch mcconnell pleads with his senators
not to force ugly vote in congress on
joe biden's electoral college victory
warning them that it would split the
party despite president's demands for a
last-ditch fight to overturn election
they say he said it was a terrible vote
because republicans would ultimately
have to vote it down
and would appear like an anti-trump move
alabama oh seriously don't support trump
because it'll look like we're anti-trump
alabama representative mo brooks said he
will formally challenge the electoral
college votes
during congressional election
certification on january 6. he insisted
tuesday
that if all legal votes were counted and
all illegal votes were thrown out
trump would emerge as the real electoral
college winner
trump reposted an article tuesday with
brooke's comments
a senator would need to join brooks and
others in the house to officially launch
deliberations on an electoral college
vote challenge
mcconnell's for the first time on
tuesday called joe biden the
president-elect
following the electoral college
cementing his victory on monday the
electoral college has spoken mcconnell
said on the senate floor
so today i want to congratulate
president-elect joe biden so this is why
it matters
you've got a ton of republicans in the
house that are saying straight up
we're going to organize you a challenge
they need a republican senator to sign
on with them
if these okay so we we have these
unofficial
electoral votes it is what should have
been
or i'm sorry what would have been the
republican elector slates
decided to cast what they called
procedural votes in the event that
something happens and these in these
elections are overturned
then they'll have those votes cast and
available for certification
if mike pence wants to potentially count
those votes
theoretically i guess he can maybe it'll
go to the supreme court or they'll
probably just
throw it in the garbage i mean they're
unofficial and
look the establishment very much is not
in favor of trump but
mike pence is going to have to choose
for himself i mean he's running as well
if the senate republicans vote to ch and
they choose these seven unofficial
procedural votes for some reason maybe
some information comes out
and the house chooses the official
electoral college as it stands now
then you've got a disputed election with
both chambers disagreeing and i don't
know how mike pence would decide
but if there's no dispute among any of
these votes
then i don't see how this is we get
anything other than
joe biden winning so i don't know what
you guys think but
i am not surprised mitch mcconnell is
basically saying don't support trump in
this effort
just let it go joe biden won what do you
think i mean
cassandra your trump supporter yeah yeah
um well there is president
for those procedural votes going in in
1960
when john f kennedy was running
um they did a procedural vote away from
the democratic slate
in hawaii i believe and 11 days after
the certification
they ended up uh they ended up getting
within to kennedy
this was uh the republic the republicans
claimed they won they were like we won
certifications over
bam they stamped the p they stamped the
official certified vote
and sent the republican votes to
congress while
legal challenges were still pending a
recount 11 days later found
actually you didn't win so they had to
then take the other procedural votes and
then certify them
richard nixon got both sort of both
votes both stamped the governor's
approval
and he said we're going to count the
democrat once because of what happened
so that's possible it could happen right
now and it's really funny
i actually did a video the other day
talking about this and facebook i got
one of those fake news flags saying
but that so i like i basically said the
beginning of my video
these votes right now they're unofficial
they're not from the you know the
governor
but in 1960 here's what happened so look
my personal opinion is i don't think
it's gonna work
i think they'll likely be thrown out and
it was probably you know a symbolic vote
maybe mike pence says these are not
officially certified i'm not gonna count
them
they labeled it fake news actually i got
it lifted though i emailed saying like
what was wrong about anything i said
and they're like oh well i guess you're
right and they removed it but
i bring that up because it's really
weird it literally happened
like the the so you have these different
uh electors
and people voted for them the democrat
electors were the ones who were chosen
to go to the state house and cast votes
but the republican electors who didn't i
i
i guess they're arguing that they're not
electors they're electoral candidates
that's what they they claimed right
speaking
speaking some it's like a semantic
argument yeah you know what we mean
fine electoral candidates for the
republican cast a procedural vote so
it's on record
and they're trying to shove it under the
rugs it's not happening but even now if
mitch mcconnell is on board
newsmax is saying it betfair this is
really funny betfair
closed the the betting and paid out
everybody who bet on joe biden
even though january 6 is the official
constitutional day
and it's so people this is interesting
betfair
said that in the event trump does
somehow become president they'll revisit
this
so now trump's reporters saying betfair
just placed a billion dollar bet that
joe biden is
does have it i think it's a fair bet to
be honest
but it is kind of interesting that
they're you know willing to actually
stake that
considering january i think they would
have just waited it would be so much
easier just
a couple of weeks just don't even like
it's a couple weeks back a couple weeks
till uh
or you could wait till inauguration day
is it because they wanted to flesh out
their books before the turn of the the
year
yeah could be yup close out the books
before the year's over
yeah how interesting would that be if
like come january 6 something happens
not only that what if you know so joe
biden was coughing right
everybody saw joe joe biden coughing and
they were like he's got he's got coveted
right
what if the next president is camillaris
and betfair is just like
oh no everybody bet wrong and then they
gotta give to all the kamala people
well the senate minority leader comments
are pretty interesting chuck schumer
said
that the republicans should follow
mcconnell's lead
and acknowledge that joe biden will be
the next president of the united states
and very interestingly we also have to
acknowledge
susan collins and mitt romney are
congratulating joe biden for his
presidency
romney is the bastion of conservative
conservatism in this country
that's why it's i don't think it's going
to happen look you've got what
you say murkowski and and no uh susan
susan collins and
mitt romney oh my cows markowski's
probably gonna you know be on board them
as well
so what happens if these you know
procedural votes do somehow make it to
you know to congress you've got right
there these republicans are going to be
like nah
yeah nah it's biden the gp is weak
yeah yeah there's a gop it still exists
i had no idea well i think this is their
end
mitch mcconnell just stood up and said
well sir if you're a trump supporter who
helped republicans get elected uh i have
a knife just turn around and let me pull
up your back
and that's exactly what mitch mcconnell
did because people
look at the very least they're just
saying please fight for us
like we fought for you okay maybe
trump's not gonna win
maybe all you know that that's how many
of them feel but at least give people
the courtesy of saying if we're gonna
turn out for you get you guys elected
you can do you can you can fight to the
bitter end for trump
there's constitutional procedures they
can challenge the votes
they can lose and they can say look we
tried we did everything no he's already
like bye-bye and the best part is a
couple weeks out from the georgia
runoffs
how many people now are going to be like
sacrifice the senate
yeah don't let republicans win i mean
i've been
debating this internally for some time
now because i
you know writing for gateway and stuff
it's like i've had a lot of pressure to
write pro you know pro georgia articles
like being like hey go
go vote but i don't want to
i don't i'm like what is the gop done
for us
like why should i do anything for them
i'm not writing any of this i don't care
but you're not a republican right no
yeah i'm a trump supporter
i am i am not a republican i voted for
trump i support him and um
and and a bunch of some of the most
important things any president has done
especially in my lifetime trying to get
our troops out of the middle east not
perfect i know ian
drone strikes and all that stuff you've
read my mind sam better than joe biden
but i don't care like that's a low bar
though that's a very low bar
if you're making arguments saying better
than joe biden that's like saying better
than like
i mean yeah but kamala harris is under
that bar so scraping your
private parts on family-friendly show
we're not going to go in there but i'm
thinking of this one meme that i just
saw recently and it's a rick and morty
meme and rick is looking at a robot the
robot is looking at him
and is saying what is my purpose the
robot is the gop
and then rick looks at him and he says
your only purpose is to sell red hats
that's it
you sell reddit and uh there's a point
to be made there there's
there's a total fracture of the right
that you know
hasn't been effective and some people
say hasn't even been there and and
hasn't really changed things that much
at all you know republicans are really
good at republican politicians
rolling over and exposing their soft
underbelly to democrats
so so when we had michael mallison here
with jones he brought up a really really
really interesting point
he said obama wanted uh obama
got this with obamacare the individual
mandate forcing people by law
to buy health insurance otherwise you
get a fine he said okay where's the
where's the right where's the
republicans saying okay then everyone
has to buy a gun too that's the
compromise
if you want universal everyone but is my
mandate has to buy health insurance
well the republicans should save
everybody buy a gun because gun
ownership is a big conservative no
republicans never do anything like this
republicans sit back and complain the
democrats did something and then
eventually just given to the democrats
they everybody says this and i know it's
a cliche at this point but the
republican party is just
the democrat party of five years ago all
they're doing
is supporting things that the democrats
supported five years ago
they're just behind in five years
they're going to be like hey you want to
go to our republican
drag queen story hour yeah isn't that
already happening now
kinda yeah they're they're they're
they're going to 100
they're gonna in five years they're
gonna be like what do you think we need
credit
mitch mcconnell well i don't know if
mitch mcconnell will still be in in five
years
how old is mitch mcconnell old old
he is indeed turtle old turtle he's
going to be okay so he'll be really old
older than he is now i mean like that
that
image that went around of his hands like
that i feel bad you know what i mean
like
i think it's i think it's messed up when
people made fun of him because he
tripped at one time you guys remember
that
yeah because because what he had polio
in his kid or something right
something like that no idea was it not
polio i don't know he had something so
like he's like you know probably his leg
and he tripped and everyone's making fun
of him like dude
i don't like the guy he never liked the
guy but i'm not gonna
brag on him or anybody else because they
stumbled and you know that's messed up
but in five years they're going to be
advocating for universal basic income
yeah he's going to be like i've always
been in favor of universal mexican
income
and all the republicans are going to be
like well you know it's something i
gotta fight for meanwhile the democrats
are in favor of
like the you know i don't even know how
far left you go at that point
how can you go further i don't know
where they'll manage they'll find them
they'll figure it out
and the the republicans will manage to
continue to lose gracefully
yep yeah that's that's that's that's
what we've got so far
so what do you guys think there what do
you think trump supporters are going to
do i mean what are you going to do who
are you going to vote for what's
like i don't know i mean
everybody's propping up dan crenshaw for
2024 and nikki haley
i would rather i would vote for a
literal communist
just burned down before i would vote for
either of those two neocons like
i would just be like burn it all down go
ahead you know
alexandria ocasio-cortez or whatever
do your thing burn it down it's like the
the the
swing the hard swing back and forth left
and right yeah send a message vote for
aoc
i guess i could see him start a new
political party
i actually saw a poll recently that i
think it was something like 79
of republicans so they would follow
trump to a new party he needs to do it
and
we need we need it in this country the
problem is if the
left doesn't start their own like
progressive party
then it's just going to split the
republican vote good but if
you know they have the people and they
have the support for a progressive party
they could easily do like a bernie
sanders
type party and split the democrats and
then we split the right
and then there would be four yeah a
populist anti-establishment party
because there definitely seems that
there is a political realignment
and it's not working out in anyone's
favor it's the establishment
taking advantage of that and screwing
everyone over and people are realizing
it and that's why when me and tim were
talking about earlier today we're like
i think there's going to be another
major occupy wall street movement as you
were telling me that some people on the
far
left might join people on the right and
come together on their disagreements
but not not like they're gonna form one
group together yeah so we've got the
autonomous zone in portland
where armed leftist militias have
secured like four square blocks or
something
and they've set booby traps you guys see
the story oh they're running around with
like
ar-15s yeah yeah they're these people
don't mess around like
i mean you saw what happened in chaz
when they pumped 300 rounds into that
white suv killing those two teenagers
yeah dude more of that is gonna happen
these people in portland have taken this
the space because there's this house
they call it like the red house occupied
zone or whatever autonomous own this
house was owned by a family and they're
now being evicted because they couldn't
pay their bills
you know what man i'm not uh i'm not
gonna defend the the state or the police
on this one
you can't shut people's businesses down
and then the cops come in and tell
people they're not out to work
and then come back months later back now
we're taking your house it's like nah
but didn't that family own another house
that they're living in and
get 300 000 from gofundme so
this is where story hearts get
interesting i think it's really cool
they raised the 260 000 to pay for the
house right congratulations
that's awesome that's organizing that's
how that's how you help people but they
do own another house not that far away
which is why the occupation is just in
my opinion exploitation right
these people find an opportunity to
seize territory and you know take space
so i'm not in favor of them using that
as an excuse but at this point
i i don't know man watching all these
cops you know enforce these
unconstitutional edicts not even laws
like watching these videos where the cop
is like it's just the law ma'am i have
to do it and they're like what law
there's no law it was never passed by
anybody the governor just told you to do
it you're doing it
and they do so i'm like listen why
should i go and defend these blue cities
that voted for this stuff that agree
with this stuff and are now complaining
about it
i mean i feel for the for the business
owners who have you know lost their
businesses who are having their lives
destroyed
absolutely but they voted for all these
people but so so back to luke's point
in this one town in uh what's going on
boston
mossy brook yeah in washington they the
the mayor basically said
we are not we are completely in defiance
of the coveted lockdowns
and everybody can do whatever they want
live their lives like normal and patriot
prayers showed up in this big event
that's basically they're not calling it
an autonomous zone but saying that you
were exempt from the state's
laws and or i'm sorry not laws edicts
and you're going to operate
independently essentially this it's it's
similar
not the exact same thing but what
happens now if the state sends in police
to shut it down and start shutting
people's businesses down they're not
going to support them
and then what happens when in washington
they see this autonomous zone in
portland or whatever
why would they defend the cops shutting
down that they're going to be like i
don't care
leave me alone already on the donald.win
which is the big trump supporting reddit
they're mocking michigan police officers
because they kept out the electors
the republican slate from going into the
capital building so i think
it's entirely possible we get to a point
where you see more cities like this
doing more towns like this doing this
stuff
when biden gets elected he's going to
try and say stuff and the republicans
are going to or you know the people the
regular people are going to be like nah
and auntie was going to be like why
would we intervene and the right's going
to be like why would we intervene with
them we don't live there and we don't
have anything to do with them
and the way they vote so then
essentially you've got three factions
the establishment
political apparatus the populist left in
the populist right
and as the saying goes the enemy of my
enemy is my friend if the left and the
right aren't interacting in these towns
or cities why would they be opposed to
each other yep
and a lot of low information voters are
about to get a very rude awakening with
the corporatist presidency of biden
that just today announced two major
goldman sachs executives a part of his
administration
and if you look at if you look at his
administration it's like who's who's of
the
family-friendly show here of the
underworld
the greasiest nastiest swamp
creatures that could ever exist that are
even more disgusting behind cassandra's
back right there with that cartoon of
joe biden eating a little baby
that's practice that's that's that's
somewhat based on reality but that's a
whole other topic of discussion to talk
about here but
we're talking about goldman sachs we're
talking about big tech we're talking
about big banks we're talking about big
corporatist
institutions that are at the helm of
major decisions
for the united states in the upcoming
future a lot of people are going to have
a very rude awakening to that and with
that i think there's going to be another
spur
of an occupy wall street movement which
i think is really going to be powerful
really going to be significant and
something really to look up thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you